turn around do not face me turn around
just walk right here walk right here
shut the fuck up get right over here i
don't give a fuck who you are get on
your knees hey i'm a cop
then you'll listen to me when i tell you
to get on your
boss man you know how many people are
involved in this
yeah we are
and
and if i came to your county and i put
you in this position
i'll take you home you take me home
you take me home after your sergeant
shows up on scene and everybody's got
cameras
yeah
i know that's what we're supposed to do
but
unfortunately i can't do that
you're gonna tell me i go to miami dade
and i flee from the cops i'm gonna walk
home
is that what you're telling me
nah man come on don't give me that
bullshit we're supposed to be brothers
right
come on boss
your family
yeah bro you know i can't turn off my
camera come on
nobody sat in this chair
has ever thought they did anything wrong
okay but today but today
today i'm not gonna listen to any shit
about how i did this okay
all right just have a seat boss
what's your uh
i didn't get your deal what's your full
name
call the pba
you gonna call me pba
yeah you can call whoever you need to
call i brought your phone so you can
make all the phone calls you need you
can't got a big date you can't call
right now all i need is i'm not asking
you any incriminating questions you know
i'm not going to do that donna morales
doesn't
last name is ross
rojas r-o-j-a-s
what's your middle name
william
0-7 26 1990 foot
good
okay
stand up
sit down
[Music]
you have anything in your mouth dentures
are supposed to be no i'm not in the
blood so
okay no worse i still got to check them
out stick your tongue
let's go
[Music]
so
[Music]
three
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
fleeing flame
really
apple door oh man
you pulled over
after almost five miles
ready i didn't even notice you bro
and i'm sorry about that but i pulled
over as soon as i want to see
that's crazy you know
you know i want to talk to you
but you're telling me that you don't
want to talk with me but now you're
talking with me so i don't i don't know
what it is that you want me to do
okay
okay i i'm trying to level with you
yeah pull door as soon as i saw it
literally
okay so so boss listen
have you you exercise your right to
remain silent or you want to talk with
me that's crazy
so
so
so
put it on whenever you can kind of make
a phone call yes
your phone's in the car give me just a
little bit you know this is going to
take about 20 minutes
so
so
i like it can i call my legal help
just to make sure
i do the things right
what do you want me to do right for you
right now my legal oh
okay i just want to do things the right
way all right so
right now i'm not going to ask you any
questions i'm not going to i'm not going
to do anything
let's get over by the president okay and
you already told me you're not going to
do it i'm just going to it's not dad
like i just want to call the legal home
make sure i do the thing right right all
right so you're not gonna have to do
anything right now i'll get you i just
wanna call my legal help no make sure
i'll do the right thing the right way i
brought your phone
so you can make your phone call three
one five all right but right now i can't
i can't give any phone calls right now
okay as soon as we're done here you can
make whatever phone calls you need
that's why i brought your phone
make sense you're trying you're trying
to book me before like me economy go
to blow a blow like i wanna i just want
to be able to call him okay
here's what we're gonna do
three more five stop can we just say i
gotta get it i gotta get it all right
you realize that nobody else in this
room gets this right
all right so
what's the phone number
the phone number here you said three
would you hear that i have it in my
fucking my badge you saw it like
i'm sure your partner has it i don't
have your phone on me it's in the car
bro i know but i'm sure your partner has
my legal
okay you want to call it can you search
over like the contact link called pba
that's right
just a little bit
that's three more five seven seven nine
thank you for calling the south florida
pda the voice
during our normal working hours 9 a.m to
5 p.m
oh
they don't have an emergency number here
ross
i'm not going to ask any questions but i
will tell you this is not an
incriminating question i'm telling you
every agency has a certain policy and i
don't know what yours is
but the agency has a policy on whether
you get arrested for dui and whether or
not you blow
i don't know what yours is
so good
what's up
how does your booking work
we're going to go across the street
literally across the street to the jail
uh you'll make whatever phone calls you
need they'll take your phone so that you
can get whatever phone numbers you need
you'll see
the judge
in the morning
they do work on something they do work
on sundays
and
i have no doubt that they'll
not a promise but i don't have any doubt
that they'll let you up
um
what are you talking about
really yeah
that's good
awesome some decisions that i don't get
to make
yeah no there is
no there are some that i can make there
are some that i can't yeah okay
i don't know
i just really dig but like i pulled over
um honestly when i noticed that shit
i feel i just read it i get i understand
that shit
i pulled over but we're fleeing bro like
you know i ain't losing like
uh
and can you contact your partners and
let me give them a pbr please
they don't have your phone your phone is
in my car let's park that outside
remember
yeah my phone like your phone my badge
and my all that shit like what we're
trying to figure out right there yeah
we're pleased we're trying to that's
what i'm asking
[Music]
i think my sergeant spoke with you or
what is it a cruise
that's pissed
what did you want us to call
what's up
that's what i'm calling pba that's right
all right make sure the things the right
way that's it i understand as well
i
launch me bro
that's doing it dirty bro
i can i get you a job whatever it is
three cop cars
behind you they literally lit you up
right next to you
they lit you up next to you
and you still kept going at 111
up next to you next to you and pulled
all right no bro no you didn't pull over
you went for another three miles
and what's the mall
right there right i literally saw the
next turn
that's all right
well you know what fleeing and looting
is i would hope you know
i hope you know like bro i've been in
gangs for three and a half years i know
what fleeing and looting is
[Music]
again it is
[Music]
you know what
you can sell me all the
fairy tales and
i'm pulling over but like absolutely you
can sell me all of that
okay okay i understand like maybe i was
looking on my phone or something but i
pulled over when i once i saw the red
and blues like i did like this
motherfuckers that shit that's like
doing me dirty bro i think so
really so what how what am i supposed to
explain to to my supervisor my sergeant
the sergeant that was on scene what am i
supposed to explain to that person when
they asked me
what you did you literally arrested me
brother
yeah exactly what you're doing you're
arresting me
expensive
that's it literally
can you bring your supervisor
yeah
he might be coming here in just a little
bit
please
there's no reason to get to that extent
because like i i didn't mean that
you know i ain't no douchebag i'm a
fucking car bro like
like really looking forward
that's it that's that's dirty bro
you know there ain't no disbag bro
please just
don't say anything okay
i ain't saying that
i'm just saying what i feel
so
uh
[Music]
yeah
once we get to my car i'll let you use
your phone
before we go to the jail okay
i don't have your phone with me right
now okay boss i don't know what you want
me
i try to give you my phone but you don't
remember the phone number i don't
actually want to stay involved hold on
my father's a cop
you gave it to me but i gave my paper to
a sword
give me a second
so
hmm
ugh
i'm gonna see what i can do about the
felonies here
i make no promises
but i'm gonna try
ah
uh
bro
okay i gotta read you something you know
how this works all right let's just
listen first if you have any questions
i'll be reading it let's order this just
i gotta do it
okay i got it i gotta read this to you
anyways
i'm not requesting that you submit to a
lawful test of your breath for the
purpose of determining its alcohol
content
if you refuse to take the test requested
your driving privilege will be suspended
for a period of one year for a first
time refusal or 18 months if your
driving privilege has been previously
suspended or if you if you have been
previously fined under section
327.35215 of the four statutes for
refusing to submit to unlawful testing
your breath your inner blood
additionally if you refuse to take the
test i have requested of you and if your
driving privilege has been previously
suspended or if you have been previously
fined under section 327 35215 for
committing a misdemeanor in addition to
any of the penalties i'm sorry for a
refusal to submit 12 tests to your
breath your inner blood you will be
committing a misdemeanor in addition to
any other penalties which can be opposed
by law
refusal to submit to the test i have a
question of you is admissible to
evidence in any criminal proceeding
you understand all
i know you want legal advice but i got
to remind you
right now your right to an attorney
doesn't attach when it comes to the
breath test you already consented to the
breath test when you got a driver's
license you know that so all i got to do
is read this to you and you make a
decision as a big boy knowing your
agency's policies and these consequences
okay
tell me what you want to do
[Music]
refuse okay i'm going to ask you one
more time when this ready
i hope you give me a call
[Music]
i would like to tell my kpis i know
whether to blow or not
i i don't know my fucking legal shit
obviously though all right
i i would like to talk to people like if
they told me to blow up
[Music]
my phone like
three more five seven seven nine
or my badge like i have my badge there
on my pba for one day
[Applause]
[Music]
are you willing to provide a brush
does it okay but i need an answer and
say yes or no all right
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
put the cuffs in the back stand in the
front
um
[Music]
[Applause]
hand over your rental to your people
what's up my man
he's in the front because he's a cop
okay so
all right you got to get off the phone
now boss okay they're gonna let you make
some more phone calls in just a little
bit all right have a good one
they tell me to get out of the hole now
all right
these two citations i need you to sign
it's not an admission of guilt it just
says you received all right
that's one
okay
there on that line right here this way
diabetes
that requires medications
[Music]
what's your birthday 7 26.95
uh
you